[Musique]
essuyez-vous la bouche
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau d'affaires conclue et là pour
moi c'est la dernière fois que je
prononce cette phrase puisque je quitte
cette émission mais j'ai trouvé une
jolie remplaçante jolie et compétente
c'est Julia qui va reprendre les reines
et faire conclue merci Sophie c'est
l'unité
c'est l'addition la martingale c'est la
volonté et dans ce que tu viens de faire
aujourd'hui monsieur 1er ministre non
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
Elisabeth
tu sais que je t'aime
le 5 ou le 9 le 9
pour 6 points ça ne s'arrange pas empire
c'est ce qu'on appelle la recommandation
horizontale c'est des gens comme vous
qui donnent leur avis par rapport à ce
qu'on appelait avant la recommandation
verticale vous imaginez c'est l'expert
qui dit à tous les couillons il faut
faire comme ça non désormais c'est des
gens qui me ressemblent qui donnent leur
avis et donc on les croit davantage
parce que c'est des gens comme nous en
tout cas c'est sympa de traiter tous
ceux qui nous regardent écoute de
couillon mais on est tous pour ce qu'on
ne connaît pas que moi je prends le
nombre de consuels je crois que le
nombre de gens qui se laissent empêcher
et je suis inquiet de voir que les
Français ça prend en train de devenir
des veaux alors qu'ils écoutent je
préfère la vie reste libre je pensais
pas tomber sur vous je suis déçu
vous aimiez beaucoup Sophie Davant mais
on l'aime tous aussi d'avant
complètement je suis complètement fan de
ménage d'ailleurs dites moi Janine c'est
nickel nickel ça
oh oui oui
les mâles investissent un coin de récif
pour faire une démonstration de leur
vigueur
cette femelle est venue assister au
spectacle
[Musique]
comme un pan qui fait la roue le mâle
avance et recule en déployant sa
nageoire dorsale et en affichant ses
couleurs c'est pénible que les hommes
continuent à expliquer aux femmes ce que
c'est le consentement en fait je pense
que il y a des très beaux témoignages de
femmes qu'on a trouvé dans la
littérature ces dernières années qu'on a
trouvé sur les réseaux ces dernières
années donc maintenant on va écouter les
femmes et on va les laisser dire
qu'est-ce que le consentement
impeccable tu fais une surprise tout de
suite regarde
la citation
faute de bip comment toi d'une carotte
les hommes je crois que je l'ai écouté
la femelle semble impressionner ensemble
ventre contre ventre il s'élève à
environ un mètre dessus du récif il
libère en même temps leur semence
reproductrice en un instant le spectacle
est terminé Bénédicte tu aimerais avoir
des enfants ce que je peux comprendre
mais à mon âge 53 ans je ne pourrais pas
combler tes rêves par contre je peux
combler ton manque d'amour ton vide
d'amour et de bonheur c'est le même trou
qui n'attend que d'être comblé
[Rires]
voici la première citation mais on peut
jouer quand même bah oui vise la belle
paire de bip oh ça suffit maintenant
quand tu démontes un lit
toi tu te dépêches un
petit salon en plus c'est bon
si seulement c'était plus long
[Musique]
que tu avais un trou à remplir
et ma chatte qui s'appelle
Talia
[Musique]
le montrent tête baissée museau à demi
masqué comme pour préserver son anonyme
car ce caniche a fait tomber un gros
bonnet de la mafia Luigi Katia plus
Authie 64 ans condamné à 15 ans de
prison était recherchés depuis 6 mois
les enquêteurs le savaient cacher
quelque part dans cette ville de la
région napolitaine il cherchait la bonne
maison et le chien les a aidés malgré
lui c'est la mère qui a ouvert
prolongée du secteur nous avons détecté
la présence du chien de la compagne du
fugitif à la fenêtre d'une maison nous
avons donc décidé de faire irruption à
l'intérieur et nous avons eu
confirmation que nous étions au bon
endroit le drone des carabiniers riz a
filmé l'opération on voit une dizaine de
policiers sauter la clôture et
s'introduire dans la ville le mafieux
sera cueilli sur son transat au bord de
la piscine
il faut partir à poil
en quoi cette étude japonaise était
intéressante
ils ont observé plus de 7000 bébés
âgés d'un an et c'est nouveau car la
majorité des études sur les écrans
concernent souvent des enfants un peu
plus âgés leur premier constat c'est
qu'un grand nombre de bébés passent trop
de temps devant les smartphones les
tablettes ou même les jeux vidéos
j'aimerais bien nous parce que vous nous
expliquiez est-ce que vous connaissiez
notre émission ou pas je la connais je
l'ai déjà vu mais donc moi je suis le
midi je regarde pas la télé pour 30%
d'entre eux c'est une à deux heures par
jour devant les écrans pour 18% d'entre
eux c'est de 2 à 4 heures par jour c'est
assez similaire en France des deux ans
en enfant pas son moyenne 56 minutes par
jour devant en un cran ça grimpe à 1h20
à 3 ans et demi et le deuxième constat
des chercheurs est tout aussi édifiant
il y a un lien entre le temps d'écran et
des retards de développement qui
apparaissent dès l'âge de deux ans quel
est votre émission favorite à la télé et
votre présentateur ou animateur télé à
apparition il y a pas de problème moi
j'aime bien je regarde Nagui les
chansons je regarde Nagui à la 2 alors
j'ai précisé que mélodie était pilote de
ligne Johan travaille dans une banque le
point commun le vol que voulez-vous 30
40 ou 50 points ça m'avait vraiment dans
le canailler ça m'avait tellement manqué
je suis désolé